ثم الدعوات المتكرره من قبل الخارجيه
البريطانيه الى عدم اعدام علي اكبري مضت
ايران قدوما باعدام المواطن الايراني
البريطاني بعد ثلاثه اعوام من اعتقاله وهو
ما اثار حمله تمديد حكوميه واسعه حذرت من
ان الاعدام لن يمرر الكرام اولى الخطوات
المتخذه فرض عقوبات على المدعي العام
الايراني رئيس الوزراء البريطاني رشيش
هناك اعتبر ان الاعدام عمل قاسم وجبان
نفذه نظام همجي لا يحترم حقوق الانسان في
ما اعتبره وزير الخارجيه انا اعدام اكبر
في ايران يستحق الادانه بكل العبارات
ادانه بدا يتساءل الكثيرون عن شكل تنفيذها
من قبل الحكومه البريطانيه حيث دعى نواب
الى ضروره اخذ موقف اكثر حزما لحمايه
المواطنين البريطانيين مزدوجه الجنسيه
فيما دعى نواب الى ضروره اتخاذ خطوات تعكس
مدى الاستياء من التهديدات الايرانيه التي
طالت مقيمين في بريطانيا وهو مد بريطانيا
الى دراسه قرار ادراج الحرس الثوري
الايراني على قائمه الارهاب قرار قد يصبح
اكثر الحاحا مع تنفيذها عمليه الاعدام بحق
اكبر
بريطانيا ربما منح اعدام اكبر اهتماما
عالميا واسعا حرم منه العشرات من
الايرانيين الذين ينتظرون تنفيذ حكم
الاعدام بحقهم بسبب مشاركتهم في المظاهرات
وهو ما جعل توقيت اعدام اكبر يزيد من نبره
التمديد البريطانيه بتحركات الايرانيه هنا
من لندن عروب عبد الحق العربي العربيه